si durísimo discurso el de Vladimir
Putin que ha rubricado la anexión de las
provincias de toniers Sa purilla y Jason
al menos de la parte que ahora mismo
controla Rusia Aunque parece que en la
mayoría de los casos no renuncian al
resto rutina atacado accidente ha
llamado colonial y ocupante a Estados
Unidos y ha dicho que aunque está
dispuesta a negociar kiev tiene que
ahora parar la guerra y que esta anexión
no es reversible que todas esas personas
que sean criado en las provincias de
donía ese lugar sa polilla y jerson van
a ser ciudadanos rusos para siempre
nueva advertencia y no es la primera en
este mes va a defender sus nuevos
territorios utilizando todos los medios
disponibles ha dicho sin hacer
referencia explícita al armamento
nuclear En todo caso a partir de ahora
una situación de máxima incertidumbre
mientras desde kiev el presidente
Ucrania
ha pedido el ingreso urgente por la vía
rápida de Ucrania en la